whether it's a zombie movie with the
heart of a romance or a look at the
Terrors of being a parent these horror
flicks aren't properly understood by
many of the people who watch them
based on the novel by Jeff Vandermeer
Alex Garland's Annihilation has one of
the most confusing and thought-provoking
movie endings of the last decade
biologist Lina takes the journey into
the unknown after her husband Kane
returns from a three-year disappearance
with some rather strange changes she and
a team of women enter the mysterious
meteor followed Zone known as the
Shimmer to try and find out what exactly
happened to Kane while he and his team
were inside if you're looking for a
straightforward answer to this setup
Annihilation won't exactly deliver
instead Annihilation skirts the fine
line between horror and sci-fi as Lena
and her crew discovered the DNA mixing
properties of the alien presence when
Lena arrives at the Lighthouse at the
center of the Shimmer she has an
encounter that leaves her a changed
woman quite literally the ending of
annihilation has sparked a lot of debate
some believe it to be a metaphor
concerning death or disease but Garland
has said that it has to do with
self-destruction he's in
self-destruction coded into a programmed
into each cell whatever the meaning it's
an ending that's nearly impossible to
forget
considered by many to be director Dario
argento's magnum opus Suspiria takes on
the occult in a manner that has inspired
countless copycats since the film's 1977
release Suspiria is a visual spectacle
first and foremost and that's far from a
Bad Thing told in argento's signature
grand gignol style which relies more on
Ultra violence and rooting tone than
telling one cohesive story Suspiria
follows dancer Susie Banyan to Germany
as she joins the prestigious tens Dance
Academy to perfect her ballet abilities
it's impossible not to be drawn into
Susie's surreal new world as strange
things begin happening around her she
gets sick the school suffers a maggot
infestation and the blind pianist is
killed by his own dog so it's no real
shock when Susie discovers that this
illustrious dance school once was and
still is which is oven while this is the
first entry into argento's three mothers
Trilogy Suspiria is a delightfully
cryptic watch that'll stick with you
long after the credits roll at 23 years
old director Don pascarelli kicked off
his filmmaking career with a head
scratcher that's equally imaginative and
horrific Phantasm follows a boy named
Mike who witnesses a body being stolen
from the local Cemetery this leads Mike
and his brother Jody on an investigative
mission to check out the mausoleum where
they happen upon an evil mortician
better known as the tall man who has the
power to reanimate corpses this
discovery sends the tall men on a
mission to capture Mike and Jody
birthing his iconic horror movie
catchphrase
[Laughter]
boy okay of course you can't forget
about the murderous silver ball that
flies into people's skulls with the sole
purpose of retrieving brain meat for the
late 70s Phantasm was definitely a
horror film that left audiences wanting
more the third act falls apart a bit
leaving audiences wanting to know
exactly why the tall man is doing what
he's doing thankfully pascarelli
returned to the world and characters he
created nine years later with 1988's
Phantasm 2 kicking off a quirky and gory
little franchise beloved by many Die
Hard horror fans when it comes to style
over substance Beyond the Black rainbow
is a poster trial for the phrase Panos
cosmaros 2010 debut is chock full of
trippy visuals and synth-filled
soundscapes but when it comes to story
there's not much of one at all Elena is
a mute girl with psychic powers kept
prisoner in an institution by a crazed
doctor who loves watching her meltdown
on his many windows and monitors of
course when she figured out how to
hardest her abilities she escapes in a
mind-bending extended sequence overall
The Narrative of Beyond the Black
rainbow boils down to the conflict
between doctor and patient using its
surreal futuristic looking hospital as a
unique backdrop as surreal as the
imagery is though nailing down an actual
plot becomes quite difficult when
pressed cosmetal's Stylistics Slow Burn
was undoubtedly meant to appeal to
audiences on a more subconscious level
when viewing Beyond the Black rainbow
with those expectations in mind one may
finish viewing the movie in an altered
mindset but if you're looking for a
clear-cut first second and third act and
it might be best to look elsewhere after
the breakout success of Drive many
anticipated Danish filmmaker Nicholas
winning refined to go on to make some of
the next decades action Classics instead
refin followed up the stylish Thriller
with too much more baffling films the
second of which was the L Fanning LED
fashion Wharf like the neon demon
Fanning plays Jesse a young fashion
model who has recently moved to Los
Angeles there she meets models Gigi and
Sarah and their makeup artist Ruby who
immediately take an interest in her as
Jesse gets closer and deeper she finds
something extremely dark hiding beneath
the beautiful facade what's wrong with
that anyway
women would kill to look like this as
weird as things already were the ending
really takes a turn when Jesse finds
herself the victim of her new peers
cannibalistic impulses on the surface
the twist in the neon demon serves as a
metaphor for the pain you face if you're
a model or actress the system will
change your values and then Eat You
Alive however there's also a deeper
layer here Gigi's body rejects Jesse's
organs which symbolizes how she'd become
rotten or impure in the process of
entrapping and capturing their prey
these siren-like Predators have ruined
what made Jessie desirable in the first
place
long before Peter Jackson made a name
for himself with the Lord of the Rings
movies he brought 1992's Bonkers horror
goody Dead Alive originally titled brain
dead to the world Dead Alive is a simple
New Zealand Love Story buried deep
inside a zany Undead apocalypse hapless
hero Lionel Cosgrove struggles to keep
his Suburban family together after a
disease from a Sumatran rat monkey
starts to turn normal people into
flesh-eating zombies of course things
don't go according to plan meaning it's
not long before he has to take things
into his own hands shedding tons of
zombie blood along the way to save
Paquita his one true love you can easily
bypass any confusion by looking at Dead
Alive as a story of love and Redemption
but there's a whole lot of family drama
included in Jackson's tale that gives
the story some weird uncomfortable
layers the Gory combination of humor and
horror puts this gross-up flick in a
category all its own
Stephen King may have gone on record
many times regarding his disdain for
Stanley Kubrick's 1980 adaptation of his
classic story The Shining but the Jack
Nicholson and Shelley Duvall starring
film is a classic for a good reason
intense performances disturbing imagery
Epic camera work and twists Galore make
this movie A one-of-a-kind Masterpiece
it's inspired so many wild theories that
it'll make her head spin on the surface
King's tale explores the story of a
fractured family on a descendant of
Madness Jack tauren sent his son Danny
share telepathic abilities Danny's aware
of it but Jack is not that brings things
to a chaotic and bloody Crescendo as the
family takes root in the haunted
Overlook Hotel in the dead of winter as
a horrific ghost story The Shining works
wonders but if you go deeper into the
theories about the film many of which
are outlined in the documentary room 237
you'll start seeing odd narrative layers
you may not have recognized before it's
impossible to watch the show without
having some kind of lingering
distressing question
[Music]
is over
Darren Aronofsky isn't the type of
director to Pander to the box office he
makes the movies he wants to make and
doesn't seem to care what audiences
think that's definitely a good thing
because audiences didn't really care for
mother to the point that it became one
of only a few movies to earn the lowest
possible Cinema score grade of f what
exactly is this movie about and why did
so many people hate it the latter
question is much easier to answer
Jennifer Lawrence and Javier Bardem Star
as a married couple looking to rebuild
their lives after a tragic fire as
Lawrence attempts to resurrect the home
from the ground up odd events begin to
occur that seem to link her own health
with that of the house after an
unexpected encounter with a family of
strangers Lawrence becomes pregnant with
bardem's child inspiring him to write a
poem the poem resonates with the people
a bit too much soon the house is turned
into a battlefield featuring cult
members looters and Riot please and by
the end nothing is left it's a visual on
[__] that's anxiety-inducing deeply
upsetting and downright confusing is
Jennifer Lawrence's character the symbol
of Mother Nature is param's poet really
a look at the power of humanity in
relation to Earth's slow destruction
there's a lot to unpack here for sure
but in a world of formulaic films mother
is certainly unique for better Force
after the breakout success of Jordan
peele's get out horror fans knew to
expect layers of metaphor and social
commentary from the director's next
venture what they didn't expect was that
us peele's second future outing would be
even denser in its construction well it
starts off as a home invasion movie
about a black family being invaded by a
family of doppelgangers known as the
tethered us slowly unravels Slayers of
meaning on a surface level us is
relatively easy to understand with a
final twist that changes everything you
thought you knew about the Wilson family
according to Adeline Wilson's
doppelganger read the tethered were
developed in a failed government
experiment and sealed underground for
Generations red was able to convince the
other Tethered to rise to the surface
world and take down their lookalikes and
for shocking reason of course the true
message of the film ended up going over
a lot of people's heads beneath the
rabbit eating and scissor stabbing us is
actually a metaphor about inequality and
class struggle as the tether joined
their Hands Across America they unite
forces in a way that our petty human
squabbles would never allow us to do
every David Lynch movie is confusing and
to some extent every David Lynch movie
is a horror movie that's why picking
just one to represent his entire
filmography is a nearly impossible
Choice while Mulholland Drive Inland
Empire and Lost Highway could all fit on
this list it's Lynch's debut feature
that still mystifies and puzzles viewers
after over 45 years Eraserhead is a
surrealist blackened white film that
investigates the horrors of domestic
life in The Most Extreme Ways possible
Henry Spencer lives in a Suburban
industrial Wasteland one day he's
informed that his girlfriend has had a
child but what they've created is
anything but human when she hysterically
leaves him to take care of the child for
what feels like an endless amount of
time Spencer brings us into his
hallucinatory world filled with
metaphorical visions and characters
Eraserhead ends with Spencer killing the
creature to put it out of its misery and
meeting his own strange fate but taking
these events at face value is the wrong
way to look at this deeply metaphorical
film the main theme Eraserhead
reinforces is the anxiety of Parenthood
Lynch whose daughter was nine years old
when the film was released seemingly
channeled his worries into one of the
most daringly cryptic films of the 70s
some of the weirder parts of the movie
will never be explained and that's just
the way the director likes it believe it
or not Eraserhead is my most spiritual
film now what we'll elaborate on that no
if you're looking to dip your toes into
the world of Japanese experimental
horror then 1977's house is an ideal
First Step this Japanese horror movie
from 1977 operates almost entirely in
dream logic making for 88 of the most
entertaining and confounding minutes
ever put to film in-house a schoolgirl
named gorgeous takes six friends to her
honest rural home for summer vacation
once they arrive the house reveals
itself to be a wacky Haunted Mansion
that starts eating the girls alive one
girl is eaten by a piano fingers first
another is beaten up by flying
mattresses those aren't even the
strangest things to happen in this house
there's plenty of crazy occurrences
involved in kung fu watermelon and a
cute yet Sinister cat well it's easy to
enjoy house for its visual Splendor and
absurdity there's some real depth to its
content as well director novihiko
obiashi was born in Hiroshima in 1938
and lost his childhood friends to the
atomic bomb would go on to make very
explicit anti-war movies like hanagatami
in his late career these themes of the
ways War can haunt both people and an
entire nation are present in the subtext
of this 1977 surrealist nightmare Lucas
guaragnito's Suspiria is a completely
different movie than argento's 1977
original both tonally and thematically
while the basic plot Remains the Same
Susie Banyan attends a dance school in
West Berlin in 1977. guacadino weaves
the tale that is historical meeting on
top of the already confusing story of
The Surreal original there's a number of
things the Remake has that the original
doesn't like till the Swinton in three
roles a grotesque contortion sequence
and an extra 50 minutes to name a few
the biggest difference though involves
an entirely new side plot that changes
the movie's ending in a massive way
while Susie still ultimately discovers
the true identity of mother Marcos and
the coven of witches much attention is
paid to the investigations of one Dr
Joseph Klemperer this might seem to
distract from the horror intention of
the 2018 Suspiria but the addition of
this character ties The Surreal story to
Real History compare's conflict revolves
around losing his wife in World War II
and the guilt and grief he feels are a
metaphor for living in that time period
in Germany at the end of Suspiria Susie
visits compar on his deathbed and she
grants him what he's been searching for
the truth about his wife there's a
touching tragic story at the heart of
this horrific historical epic she was
cold
when she died
she wasn't afraid
war is Hell quite literally if you're
Jacob singer in his case seen in 1990s
Jacob's Ladder it's the Vietnam War
which haunts his dreams as he tries to
live a relatively quieter life as
opposed to him these nightmares ranging
from cryptic flashbacks to faceless
demons refused to allow him to move on
Jacob's Ladder can be difficult to
follow at times but there's never any
question that the monsters Jacob sees
symbolize the post-traumatic stress
disorder that so many soldiers bring
home with them if they return home at
all Jacob's earlier life is a married
father of three is cluttered over by the
stain of his time on the Mekong Delta
but the reality of his present may be
the most terrifying thing of all what
begins as a psychological Thriller
steeped heavily in demonic symbolism
quickly turns into an allegory of Heaven
hell and the place troubled Souls can
get stuck in between what's real and
what is it does it even matter you'll
probably have to watch it through a few
times to find out Christopher Smith's
triangle is an odd movie for sure one
that feels like it may have worked
better as an episode of The X-Files this
2009 film centers on Jess a troubled
mother who goes on a yacht trip with a
group of friends from the very beginning
she's under the impression that
something's wrong after a storm hits the
boat her crew finds rescue in a passing
ocean liner and yet that foreboding
feeling only gets worse for Jess that's
for good reason there's a killer on the
boat that reveal is the first in a long
line of twists that throws just face to
face with none other than herself while
triangle relies heavily on the Trope of
a horror film time loop it's intriguing
and entertaining to watch Jess attempt
to murder every version of herself and
her friends she comes across with the
goal of breaking the cycle but no matter
how hard she tries she never quite
manages to Break Free the ending of
triangle may not provide audiences with
the clear-cut closure they expected or
hoped for but it's a thought-provoking
one that will have you thinking about
the hidden impact of everyday behaviors
Christian Bale is Unforgettable as
Patrick Bateman the psychopathic Yuppie
at the Heart of Mary Herron's adaptation
of the Brett eston Ellis novel Bayman
lives a privileged life in 1980s
Manhattan privileged enough that he
routinely gets away with the murder of
sex workers and colleagues by the end of
American Psycho it seems like Bateman is
a full-blown serial killer driven to
Madness by the lack of consequences for
his actions or is he the infamous
monologue that wraps up in the film
calls the reality of every earlier scene
into question My Punishment continues to
elude me
and I gain no deeper knowledge of myself
the confusing ending of American Psycho
left audiences stumped but it all boils
down to one factor the unreliable
narrator on one hand there's the
interpretation that Bateman is powerful
enough that he can get away with
whatever he pleases and his associates
will cover for him as horrifying as that
might be the darker ending is that
Bateman can no longer tell the
difference between his psychotic
fantasies and realities ultimately it's
left ambiguous as to how many of the
killings in American Psycho actually
happen and how much of it was in
Bateman's head
foreign